wait you didn't change your character
edit no I can't see you just white dude
I got I'm a police officer
no I'm the police officer I spent so
much time customizing this character oh
it's almost like no thank you
we just started playing oh let's get
goin cam let's go lead the way the
police officer
yeah of course stupid game I'm like I'm
wasted I'm wasting the club dance the
air space oh yeah [ __ ] oh yeah I
just pulled the mouse down when I had to
grab Denis your hands damn oh I can't
get in his mind
yeah let me yeah don't be friends hey
hey thank you
oh yeah no problem now whoo you like
this I wish I could see you cuz I look
[ __ ] insane I wouldn't be able to see
I would look at myself so great
[Music]
I'm not letting go never anything in the
world
whoa bow down before the true-true
police officer yes ma'am
forgot you can pull step look oh so damn
nice listen all we got it - oh God like
if we climb on top of it never mind your
genius
I know I'm in I'm on it I'm helping
doing a good job that way so my way oh
my god no I did it I solved it everybody
it's got a wiggle
twerk that so violet let me get on that
girl gotta find me yeah stop made it
clapping oh yeah man how you gonna now
can you read joke this was gone way what
the [ __ ] I don't think we're supposed to
pull all the way this [ __ ] sake
actually
[Music]
you did it you did it boy
hey no touchy grab grab my space with
both your hands okay damn again only you
could see what I can just key out or
Brad can just key out like any white the
whole level is white all right give it
up a double hyper give me ten can did oh
my god hell yeah yeah yeah echo me my
[Music]
crotch oh good good good
now we have to do this again hope you're
happy your bra like your eyes are your
prize
step up bro step up oh you let him walk
stepping on your hands bro
alright if you answer this question you
get the blimp okay Oh steadfast
[Music]
hold it up hold it down no fee no fees
oh yeah you wanna go bro
[Music]
my other cheek can't tell us why there
you go yeah I did it oh wait I got it
you did come back so parched in this
desert so be careful okay let's plate
this so parched what the [ __ ] does
parched me
geez I'm really parched I really perched
I surprised Park
no no no master I did let go I never
yeah I got a drink the juices I'm
surprised no yeah
I'm cured everybody easy
you did it I didn't look did it look I
did it let me help ya oh yes yes
yes so hot you like that oh ah
Sting's race your arms cuz I'm gonna go
high I'll let you go high yeah there you
go
promise I promise I catch you promise I
promise all right
[Music]
okay I catch you my kitchen you catch me
I can't see you I can't you now like
right last time I mean jump like a [ __ ]
[Music]
we did oh my god oh I'm parched
you
[Music]